who had been lined up to star as the
queen in the production and then luke
latchman who was meant to be taking over
as the leading man role in cinderella uh
have now discovered that that's not the
case luke to you first of all what
happened
um i mean so i did my five auditions for
them as you tend to do these kind of
jobs and then about eight days later i
got the the phone call where i was being
told i was going to be going from
playing ensemble roles to stepping out
into a big leading role um which you
know was for me was my big break it was
huge and the contract got negotiated
through to completion i was in for
costume measurements i had photo shoot
booked in wig fittings booked in i even
helped audition the potential
cinderellas that they had lined up um
and and then just out of nowhere i'm
sitting watching tv on a sunday evening
with a bank holiday monday coming up
and i get a message from my dad of all
people who doesn't use a lot of social
media but he managed to see it before me
um sent me a message saying oh my god
what does this mean for you it's an
article saying they're closing the show
and i just go into shock and kind of
send a message back saying it means i'm
out of a job
and so i mean it was
awful to be honest with you just awful
i mean
um excited to be joining the cast um
there's lots of friends of mine who are
in it already and um
it was it was it was just the way that
it was handled was
gross really um and i also found out
through a friend i'd come back from a
sunday lunch with my partner and had a
text message from a friend saying i'm so
sorry about the job um and i just
personally i just feel that if we have
people in you know
held in such high esteem in the industry
um behaving that way um you know these
big big companies behaving that way
what's to say that who's to say that
anyone else
can you know wants to they can treat
their their their workers like that um
it's it's a really bad example to set
for other producers yeah luke have you
heard from the producers or indeed from
sir andrew lord lloyd webber
um so i i actually haven't heard
directly at all um i i spoke to my agent
about it and asked her to send me the
email that she had been sent and
literally four minutes before the press
release they sent a very generic email
to us all literally labeled at the top
dear all and it said the exact same
information in it as the press release
and at the bottom it said so for this
reason the offer that we made to your
client is no longer available and this
is after being booked on the job for
seven weeks so i hadn't had a single
audition for seven weeks because i had
11 months of work coming up in my head
and so i declined other job offers i i
thought that's what i'm waiting for
that's my financial security so i pinned
everything on it i gave up everything to
do it and i was practicing it every day
and then it just
via social media it ended
yeah um summer
the
lord webber is blaming the pandemic for
poor
sales of tickets what would you like to
say to him
um i mean look i've had a lot of
opportunity from andrew in the past um
and as as having my family but i'd like
to say that i'm just very disappointed
um because it sets a precedent for all
big companies you know
we bring in so much revenue to um
to
the world you know to the uk
um you know as artists um and and
everyone in the industry does um and to
be sort of treated like this by a
company who
um you know are a massive company is is
incredibly disappointing and um
and
uh disgraceful
what would you like to say luke
is that specifically to to the show or
the company or once again
um if i were to say anything it's just i
i understand that business decisions
have to get made um i just wish that
we we knew more and i i guess
now you've left us really in the lurch
so
help and talk to us and
try to
you know bring us some sort of closure
on this i suppose
yeah so what happens now for you guys um
luke
back to square one back to uh trying to
find the next job and uh desperately
throwing around my cv to try and pay the
bills in the meantime um but it's back
to trying to find a job which could take
anything from two months to 20 months so
i just have to try until i can
and what about for you summer
um well i
am just teaching i have a i have a
coaching business um
that you know
doesn't
it's not the best at the moment because
i had you know stopped lots of club
having lots of clients because i knew
that i was going into this job and and
that's the the
the repercussions that that
don't seem to have been acknowledged you
know the fact that i've i've actually
turned down so much work in the last
seven weeks um and like luke hello luke
i wish we were working together um
you know in a few weeks time have have
now got to go back to the drawing board
and
find the money for my bills somehow um
like so many people in these uncertain
times um and it's just a slap in the
face because we've had two years of
unemployment and now this as well um
with from such a big producer is
it's just really upsetting and saddening